my patients ask me some pretty
interesting questions hard questions but
you really challenge me in the comments
and sometimes ask really weird ones as
well so I'm about to answer some of your
comments huge thanks to gramarly for
sponsoring this episode let's get
started PE beep beep I'm a sheep I like
that name beep beep I'm a sheep I want a
dog so badly but I'm allergic is there
anything I can do to get rid of that or
any other allergy there are some
treatments that exist where you can
actually slowly work your way out of an
allergy and there are shots there are
tablets sublingual tablets that you can
do I'm not an expert in it but I know it
does exist it's like a form of
immunotherapy I drew YouTube where does
a memory go when it's
forgotten left pinky toe and if you want
to get it back you have to only think
about the left pinky to I'm not sure
where does the memory go it just uh the
the connections aren't there to remember
it but I will say the best way to
remember something that you've forgotten
is to not think about it cuz forcing
yourself to think about it sometimes the
worst thing you can do that's why taking
time off sometimes yields the best boost
to productivity and creativity and by
the way this is the one thing that in
terms of like harmful effects of Tik Tok
that people talk about before we used to
have a lot of free time so we're waiting
for the bus we'd sit with our thoughts
and we'd be in respective we think about
stuff we'd remember memories but now
we're never alone we're always looking
at something we're always being
controlled by whatever it is we're
watching so that we don't have that free
time anymore and I worry about
that if someone has a fever that we're
trying to cool down and you only have
one ice pack where is the best place to
put it I probably wouldn't want to cool
someone's fever with an ice pack I can't
even imagine okay I'm going to remove
the term fever if I'm just trying to
cool someone down because they're having
acute hypothermia or something I would
put under the armpit the most surface
area that you're going to get contact
with the skin and it's the most surface
area with an important blood vessel the
brachial artery it's right there so
you're getting a lot of blood
circulation moving past that area I
guess you could also do it in your groin
as well but like same principle why do
we have boogers uh boogers are mucus
mucus traps unwanted substances it acts
as a barrier it's really good we like
mucus unless we have too much and then
it becomes a problem so that's when we
try and clean it out by using nasal
saling sprays why don't little kids get
sore from physical activities even
teenagers get more sore than little
kids the beauty of being young
everything is is so ready to heal so
much circulation also it's smaller so
less distance for nutrients and blood
flow to travel but the the regenerative
capacity of not just a young child but
like a baby is
incredible when babies are sick the time
for them to recover sometimes is like
this meaning like on day four sometimes
they'll look very sick and then day five
they'll look like nothing ever happened
to them it's it's incredible if a woman
gets into an accident or Falls really
hard hard could her eggs break like if
you dropped the chicken's egg on the
floor no these are not the same types of
eggs humans have different eggs they're
called eggs cuz they're part of the
reproduction cycle very different eggs
no shell on the human egg I don't have a
4.0 grade point average can I still be a
doctor yes in fact getting perfect
grades doesn't correlate with a better
physician I will say there are doctors
who just get by and finish last in their
class and those doctors are also called
doctors I have a sore inside my mouth
and it's taking forever to heal I can't
exactly put a Band-Aid on the inside of
my cheek so would you recommend anything
to help it heal faster look in general
to help sores heal faster you want to
prevent irritation and irritation can be
both chemical and physical it could be
other things but those are the two main
ones that I see happen in my practice
physical meaning you know you're chewing
on your cheek or you keep biting the
same spot of your cheek or your braces
are rubbing on your cheek chemical could
be like you ate something very spicy or
you burned your mouth uh that's like
more of a thermal one than chemical but
let's say it was a burn and then you
were eating spicy foods and citrusy
foods that can create longer lasting
inflammation irritation but then if you
have a wound or sore that's not healing
on the face or mouth it absolutely needs
to be examined because there are Cancers
of the mouth there are Cancers of the
face that happen when you have a
non-healing wound in fact on the sun
exposed areas of the face if you have a
nonhealing wound it's almost to the
level of skin cancer until proven
otherwise and mucus membranes by the way
are some of the fastest healing parts of
our bodies there's so much circulation
there that it actually heals up quite
fast what's actually happening when your
foot falls asleep either you have
suppressed the nerve's ability to fire
so it feels really numb you cut off
circulation to the limb by putting
pressure uh on a blood vessel cuz
remember if you put enough pressure on a
blood vessel you can choke it so that
the part further away from where you're
choking stops getting circulation and if
it stops getting circulation for a long
period of time those muscles are like
yeah we ain't working those nerves are
like we ain't working we're taking a
break until you fill us up and that's
when you fill the pins and needles and
all that good stuff that mechanism is
actually a good mechanism because it's
in place to warn you that hey you're
choking off your foot you should you
should change position and get up off
the toilet CU not only are you choking
off the foot you're probably raising
your risk of getting a
roid which is why I tell people not to
Tik Tok on the toilet back to the
questions in just a second but first I
want to talk to you about grammarly the
AI writing partner that helps
professionals write better and faster
sometimes I make YouTube videos like
these where I see your questions for the
very first time and answer right off the
cuff just like I do with my patients
other times though I like to write out
my videos like in this animated project
where I told stories of mysterious
deaths that doctors still can't explain
spooky writing a video like that not
only took a a lot of research but a ton
of creative effort to get the words on
the page in a way you can truly enjoy
and understand fortunately my writing
process has been made so much more
efficient thanks to grammarly but it's
not a tool to help me write more it
helps me write faster and not just on
big creative projects either I can use
grammarly to help me craft emails
between my hospital or messages to my
animating team its AI features help my
writing feel more compelling either by
improving my word choice or actually
triing out the fluff which I have a bad
habit of doing too often like right now
I also really appreciate that grammarly
does not share any of my data with other
AI language training models meaning I
can trust that all my writing and info
is private I'm always in control of my
own data not only did 96% of users say
grammarly helps craft more impactful
writing but also you can sign up right
now and download for free using my link
in the description so you too can get
started with grammar lead to make your
writing better faster is it a big deal
if I pee in the shower it all goes to
the same place down the drain anyway
doesn't it there are some positives and
Pros to peeing in the shower it saves
time it saves water but health risks
there are some unique situations here
urine is not fully free of bacteria a
lot of people think it's fully sterile
it's not really sterile remember it also
has to travel through your urinary tract
which it could pick up some pathogens
across the way when it exits your body
could pick up some pathogens so there
are some potential sources of bacteria
that being said there's bacteria all
around us inside of us that's not the
end of the world but if you have a
urinary tract infection and you pee and
you step in it and you have a cut could
you get an infection yes pretty low risk
there are also instances of issues of
almost conditioning yourself to pee
every time you hear running water like
when you're in the shower so the next
time you hear that you're going to want
to pee and it's going to be
uncomfortable there's also instances of
like people saying oh I should just pee
just in case especially in females where
they say I want to pee pee just in case
before I leave and maybe we should pee
in between classes so that I never have
to go to the bathroom if you do that too
often you can get into the situation
where you train your bladder to send
signals for you to want to pee very
early you could also cause some pelvic
floor dysfunction if you're doing it
every now and then and you don't make it
a routine thing I think the risk is
pretty low pee
away I don't know it's it's a weird
question Dr Mike do you agree with me
that your celebrity doppelganger is
Zachary Levy I don't know who that
Levi who's that do you think that is I
always thought it was ke
Reeves Matrix would it be healthier to
go barefoot all the time like cavemen
no when you go barefoot all the time you
open up yourself to Cuts scrapes
infections Bone bruises like there's all
sorts of issues that happen from that so
no protect your foots do I need to wash
my armpits if I always wear deodorant
absolutely you want to wash off the
deodorant and deodorant
is just scent and a little bit of
alcohol to kill some of that bacteria so
it doesn't actually solve the problem
and it could build up in your armpits
and then cause blockages and irritations
and ingrown hairs and all these problems
so please wash your armpits in fact the
most important places to wash groin and
armpits and the genitals I guess that is
involved in the groin if you feel cold
coming on is there actually anything you
can proactively do to shorten how long
you'll be sick there's so many cold
pills and supplements in and I wonder if
anything makes a difference the hard
answer on this is outside of the basics
I'm talking about staying well hydrated
adequate rest eating your fruits and
vegetables and proteins lean proteins
there is no magic supplement thing on in
the pharmacy that's going to do this for
you I say this as someone who lives that
by example when I'm sick I desperately
want to get better but I don't go to the
pharmacy and pick up giant mega doses of
Vitamin C I don't go pick up the zinc
tablets that promise miracle cures like
it just it's not going to help if you're
not getting adequate rest maybe you want
to taking over the counter medication to
lower your fever or your aches and pains
because that will allow you to rest
maybe you want to take a medication over
the counter that can make you sleepy so
that you get adequate rest maybe maybe
maybe in some cases that works but in
general I try to follow the Mantra of
less intervention unless it's absolutely
proven to help or I'm willing to trade
off the negatives or if I'm just giving
myself something to ease my physical
discomfort there I kind of open it up to
Grandma's cures chicken noodle soup a
little cloth pad on the scalp a little
back rub whatever whatever you want to
do you want to drink ginger
tea if it's not causing you harm and the
risk of it not working is still Zero by
all means go why is my girlfriend always
cold it seems like girls are always
colder than boys hard to make that that
distinction having lower muscle mass
lower body mass in general can make you
more cold having anemia can predispose
you to being cold thyroid dysfunction so
there are certain things but hard to
make that generalization stick what
would happen if you never got rid of a
Splinter would have live in your body
forever you can become best friends no
it can like your body can create a
little capsule around it almost like an
abscess cuz the body does a good job at
Walling off from foreign substances
ideally you don't want that to happen
cuz that could become problematic so you
want to get rid of them see Medical
Professional I don't advise people doing
it themselves unless it's like fully out
there and easy to reach even then if it
starts getting red and spreading the
redness starts spreading you could be at
risk for cellulitis Kayla YouTube have
you ever wanted to quit
YouTube there have been times where I
came close to quitting YouTube one of
those times happened to be when the
company that helped me start my YouTube
channel they kind of gave me my initial
funding and um some resources to start
the channel actually saw us after one
year and I thought we were doing pretty
decently we picked up 300,000
subscribers they said no Dr Mike we view
you as a failure you turned down some of
the sponsorships that we wanted you to
take some BS vitamin stuff and some
clothing brands that I didn't really
like I didn't want to lie to my audience
they were so mad at me that they fired
us and they labeled us a failure and in
those moments you kind of look at it and
you say look I'm a doctor I really want
to focus on medicine is this the right
path and ultimately I wanted to help as
many people as POS possible using the
knowledge that I've picked up over the
course of my career and I thought if I
could do this on a scale such as big as
YouTube I would be a better doctor I
thought I'm a family medicine doctor
when our patients were in emergency
rooms we went there when our patients
were in the offices we went there they
couldn't leave their homes we do a home
visit now my patients not literally my
patients lawyers don't come after me are
on social media so it's time that we as
family medicine doctors take the call to
action and I came back and we proved
them wrong and went viral time and time
again and now have almost 12 million
subscribers thanks to
you is cracking knuckles problematic
click here to get that answer more
responding to comments and as always
stay happy and
[Music]
healthy